here are my terms for peace the eye look
best is made of sand from now on we'll
keep it as a no-man's land between us
neither may claim it worked a little
company called Texan oil there is no oh
you hear just sand I would beg to differ
sir get ready to be rich
we have been violated the yellow belt
belongs to Noah the Sultan considers the
exploitation of the yellow belt a
violation of the treaty our people need
the well foil brains
you will March my army into the desert
while I strike it is hard
father I came here to warn you and see
how the trained army with modern weapons
you who put suspect only in weapons it's
very poor soldier
the only reason your father wants us
married so he will be free to go to
butter with my father
this wasn't a wedding it was a
declaration of war I was promised to no
man I went to my father and I chose you
I love him I don't want conflict but I
won't say from it if I was here you
happy
it's in your blood you were born to rule
what did you hide to do about me what
would you do I would kill me
you